but I just think I have incredibly sexy
and married to a very important of the
person the boobs feel because well come
on yeah no no her boobs are great
[Music]
hello I'm Anna Thompson
I'm Mindy Kaling I'm real going to be
playing first impressions for pretty 52
yeah I have no no idea I have no idea
Harry Potter's new friend here about
herself the house else what I don't know
his name
don't be got it you did it you did it I
can't believe I for a second it was in
the film with you so I thought this
character was in late night to give my
oh I don't want to fight on the wall I
want to be I want to be fighting with
you and the North we're to fight for the
North Slope for the north as the Irish
like to go to the Winterfell and help
wait for the north
nobody's out there talking about Oh
heaven knows Prince gorgeous prints
gorgeous Buddhist um
[Music]
what Inge
his noise is a horse okay I see a
seahorse a dolphin it just a dolphin
okay what's so that was so good
I'm from a famous family and in the
United States Gold Rush in the cold -
yes yes yes yes yes
perfect I'm so happy I didn't have to do
more than that you're so good Mike okay
is it it's not a dolphin again I don't
know what creature this is a horse a
horse eight just a horse a big a pig
okay
that was good that was really good I am
the Dean I Maggie Smith - today I am I
was in the system this is ridiculous I'm
a damn I was in remains of the day God's
sake don't hate everyone that's a silly
one oh but I just think a lot of
incredibly sexy and married to a very
important
and I'm like the queen if I'm America
very sexy and Beyonce knows okay uh the
boobs fear because we'll come on yeah
irenna her boobs are great well then she
does lift them in a way
oh this is what is that while misery and
everyone else Marilyn Monroe okay okay
aim well a reserved with Ennis film but
I was an American but actually it's not
that person that I played a Scottish
nanny and the Scottish nannies name in
the film that I played in did you play
in it no me no no no Oh mrs. dad very
good yes that's great Scottish George
we're good we're good
wheels wheels owner so stressful very
stress was it was it enjoyable to watch